welcome back
a college libelled a bakery with racist
fakery
but after slandering these civilians the
college must now pay
millions
yeah finally the price of being woke
might be going broke an ohio appeals
court aren't they all recently upheld a
32 million dollar victory for gibson's
bakery over false racism accusations
leveled against the mom and pop shop
the case goes back to 2016
when the bakery's owner's son stopped
three black oberlin students one of whom
was stealing wine from the store
wait so the bakery also sells wine
what is this place heaven
[Music]
well that led to protests against the
bakery in 2017.
i'm going to pretend like that didn't
happen
among the protesters was oberlin's dean
of students who handed out flyers
telling people to shop elsewhere and
accusing the bakery of racial profiling
the bakery owner sued oberlin accusing
it of damaging its business and
reputation with false accusations after
legal battle a three-judge panel ruled
against the college upholding that
multi-billion dollar ruling so the
gibsons will have their cake and a pile
of dough too and 30 mil is what the
bakery will get for a college version of
jesse smilet
so now we know the cost of woke is
precisely 32 million dollars
coincidentally that's the same amount of
money i spent last year on charity
that's her stage name
anyway
because she's a stripper
michelle
you gotta love this story coming from
berkeley right we're both berkeley
berkeley alums we are uh i love wine and
i love cake and that is heaven to me i
dream of cakes sometimes do you have
dreams where there's like tables and
tables of cake i actually do okay um so
wokism got hijacked right by this uh
because this was oh oh this is about
race
no it wasn't i read recently someone
compared wokism to the salem witch
trials yeah which lasted about what 18
months or something back in the 1690s
whatever that was and and the reason the
salem witch trials ended was because
finally the governor in massachusetts
his wife was accused of being a witch
and suddenly it hit home and now okay we
got to end the salem we're straight i
feel like maybe this woke-ism is finally
coming to its end
woke was originally supposed to be just
being aware of social issues social
justice issues it got hijacked in a big
way in this story i think exemplifies it
really well yeah kat it's oberlin more
like overlynn
that's really good thanks
feels like a shirt yeah
absolutely um i don't think she's being
sincere
no of cour i wouldn't i would always be
really i don't know i mean tens of
millions of dollars that's like a lot of
money it is yeah well for you for
anybody well for you okay yes including
for me
i don't have tens of millions of dollars
yet
um but i i just love that oberlin's
response was i mean i get the argument
for like people saying oh this is speech
blah blah but libel isn't free speech
and oberlin's coming out and saying that
this is you know going to present free
speech concerns which is not a concern
that they've ever presented right ever i
mean that school is
the like the wokest of the woke and the
fact that nobody just everyone repeated
the same thing long history of racial
discrimination long history of racial
discrimination without looking and
there's actually no history of that yeah
which there's a big difference yeah
between long and no
why why
this could be the worst thing oberlin's
ever done but then michelle who just
told me that lena dunham graduated from
overland so that's the worst thing to
ever come out of oberlin um
dunham so far so far yeah it could be of
the idiots that they're churning out
paying without financial aid about 80 uh
80 000 a year to go there and talk to
accuse a small business of racism when
you get caught stealing which is
actually what happens with the
shoplifting here in new york city
absolutely that's why the security
guards just stand there and all the
people who work in the stores it's like
okay just have that seventy thousand
dollars in luggage that you just stole
because i don't want my entire life and
livelihood ruined by you calling me a
bigot yeah that's what happens
today i bought a gibson's bakery and
candy shop t-shirt oh they got an extra
42 dollars from me and every time i wear
it it will be my own personal bite me to
people who who are trying to destroy
businesses because you're you show a
paucity of wokeness i am i can't help
but think that that purchase of your
t-shirt is a dog whistle
don't you love dog whistles just the the
words
i tell you if you look at the details of
the story they're really heinous if you
just go back to the real original case
yeah i mean it's it's egregious yeah and
the fact that this bakery is now getting
this payment is some kind of you know
reverse justice in the big cosmos but
politically when you start hearing
democratic pundits saying woke-ism is
not selling with democrats when you see
reverend al sharpton saying amer
african-american communities are really
sick of white elitists democratic party
that's a red red alert because
politics is shifting yeah it's true it
is about i mean to the point like it's
great they got this money but i think
that the owner passed away correct yeah
cancer yeah and so he didn't he didn't
live to see this but i mean hopefully
they uh
oberlo i mean oberlin's got a lot of
money but at least maybe if this story
gets publicized calling somebody a
racist and ruining their career that's
you got you've got to pay for that and
cnn and nbc and washington post did to
nicholas sandman yeah that's true
exactly all right coming up researchers
have started vibin with patients taking
psilocybin hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else